Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Canadian comedy film
called “No Men Beyond This point.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we are
introduced to a thirty-seven years old man
named Andrew Myers. He happens to be the
youngest man on earth. Father Ermanno Bassi
is also one of the few men alive. He tells us how
the extinction of the male species first started.
The father has been a priest ever since he was
a teenager and was familiar with the concept of
a virgin birth when it all started. Before the
crisis, every year about three or four women
claimed to have gotten pregnant without sexual
intercourse. It was regarded as a miraculous
and one timely event by the church, even though
scientists didn’t agree with it. But everything
changed in 1953 when in a single year, sixty-seven
women came forward claiming that they got pregnant
even though they were virgins. At the time it
first began, many people followed Christianity
which validated virgin births as miracles. Science
couldn’t prove if the claims were untrue because
there were no DNA testing methods then. The people
only had access to blood tests that proved if
someone is not the father, and there was no way
to confirm if the child had a father at all.
When it all first started people believed that
by nature, a baby can only be born when a sperm
fertilizes the egg. So, even though many women
were coming out with their stories, the only
logical conclusion seemed to be that they were
all lying. One of the first women who experienced
fatherless pregnancy was Helen Duval. She is
currently over sixty years old and is finally
sharing her story. In 1953, Helen was a young
married woman when she got pregnant. Back then,
there were no pregnancy tests so she was in utter
shock when the doctor announced her pregnancy
because she and her husband hadn’t had sexual
intercourse in over a year. The couple went for
a second appointment to see if the results were
incorrect but the results came out positive the
second time as well. Helen’s husband left her
because he thought she cheated. She doesn’t
blame him as anyone logical would have thought
the same. There was no other explanation for the
situation she was in. Over the years she told her
story to a lot of people but the harder she tried
to convince people she was telling the truth,
the crazier she sounded. Eventually, she, too,
started to believe that she was crazy. It
wasn’t until 1988 when a DNA test was developed
that people finally believed her truth.
A TV interview from 1945 shows us a man talking
about fatherless birth claims. He says that the
thousands of women from around the world coming
forth with such claims are all lying. According
to him, women are prone to hysteria by nature
which means that they are copying each
other to create this trend of false births
to hide their mischievousness. Even when
the trend began to grow to a larger scale,
the world leaders, who were all men at that time,
ignored it. Mostly because they couldn’t handle
the fact that they weren’t needed for procreation
anymore. As time went by, the more women came
forth with fatherless pregnancies, the more men
disregarded their claims. Because of this, women
began to harbor anger towards men that was soon
going to change the course of human history.
Then, sister Isabella came along. She was a
nun who was living in a convent in northern
Spain where men were strictly forbidden
from entering. But to Isabella’s dismay,
she got pregnant one day. The church, which was
run by men, wanted to do nothing with sister
Isabella and disregarded her completely. So,
she and the nuns came together and protested.
This triggered the women all around the world
who had been suppressing their anger until then.
In 1954, Women United Rally came to the streets
of Washington DC. The men in power tried to calm
them by saying that the scientists are still
trying to understand how this phenomenon can be
possible. But the protests didn’t stop there.
Women had had just enough of being called liars.
The working women stopped going to their jobs
while housewives stopped looking after their
families. They joined hands and rallied in
the streets. A clip from 1955 shows us that
Helen Duval’s husband had come looking for her
wanting to take her back as his wife. However,
Helen had come to a realization by then; she
didn’t need him for anything in her life.
Soon, women all over the world realized that the
men’s primary job was to help them procreate,
and without that, they are of no use. As the
number of fatherless pregnancies went up,
the number of sexual pregnancies went down
rapidly. Science finally came up with a
reasoning for the asexual pregnancies that were
so wildly debated. It turned out that women had
evolved into asexual beings with time. Meaning
that their eggs could create all the genetic
materials that are required for childbirth. The
process of reproduction is called Parthenogenesis.
As time passed, babies reproduced sexually
became rarer. When scientists looked into it,
they found out that eggs in women’s bodies
had stopped receiving sperm. Even if sperm
was injected into the egg, it died instantly
making sexual reproduction impossible.
In addition, because of the lack of y
chromosomes, every child that was born
as a result of parthenogenesis was a woman. Now,
the male species was on the verge of extinction.
In 1965, Eleanor Hamilton became the first woman
American president in history. As time passed,
the power dynamic shifted and more women started
being seen in powerful positions. Things started
to change when the government introduced the
“worker replacement program” according to which
every man who holds a powerful position in any
institution had to be reevaluated to see if they
are actually fitted for the job or they got it
because of their male privileges. Eleanor called
it the weeding out technique. Because of the
law, hundreds of men started to lose their jobs
and go homeless. The agitated men all moved to
the woods in the countryside waiting for women
to realize their mistakes. But by the mid 1970s,
it was clear that women do not actually need men
to survive in any aspect of their lives.
Some men began to return to society and take
mediocre jobs while others stayed on their
ground and started protesting. The leader of men,
Darius Smith claimed that their organization wants
respect and position back because women have done
enough injustice. By 1975, women represented over
three-quarters of the population of the earth.
Because of this, all women’s menstrual cycles
began to synchronize and a new phenomenon called
menstrual synchronization was discovered. Soon,
the world was united into one and governed by
an international organization called the
world’s council. The government overthrew
several military projects because they weren’t
needed anymore after world peace was established.
They also stopped funding NASA and focused
on building a cleaner and safer environment
on earth by building electric cars. To provide
men with proper accommodation, the government
created sanctuaries all around the world and asked
all the male population to move there. Men were
provided proper nutritious food, shelters, and
entertainment in the sanctuaries and were asked to
confine themselves in those particular areas.
At first, the men protested the idea but didn’t do
much when the sanctuaries were established and
they started living a quality life. At present,
Darius Smith still claims that the men are only
planning their attack in the sanctuaries and have
not accepted the idea at all. When technology
develops people start to research the cause
of asexual reproduction being possible. While
science declares it as evolution, some people
believe that a comet passed the earth closely
in 1952 and nine months later, the first asexual
baby was born which means that the comet had
something to do with the transformation. However,
the theory is claimed to be only a rumor.
Currently, thirty seven year old Andrew is the
youngest man on the earth. He works as a house
help for a family that consists of only women.
The couple, Iris Balashev and Terra Ganger
have appointed him to help them take care of
their daughters. Andrew says that he doesn’t feel
special for being the youngest man alive because
it has always been like that for him. His boss,
Iris, says that Andrew is a delightful housemaid
and is very good at his job. She likes him mostly
because he is way cheaper than a female housemaid.
She also believes that his influence will be
good on her children and grandchildren because
they will be able to live as the last few
women who have male influence in their lives.
Andrew’s other boss Terra isn’t very fond of him
because of his closeness to Iris. Iris paints
Andrew a lot which she claims is for artistic
purposes but Terra doesn’t get the point.
When the children go to the field for their
football match, they bring Andrew with them
for help but he is only allowed to stay on the
sidelines. While waiting, Andrew meets two men,
who are of course older than him. They, too, are
house help for another family of girls. Their chat
is disrupted by a teenage girl who reminds them
that a gathering of more than two men is illegal.
The guys quietly follow her orders and separate.
One day while Terra and Iris are in an interview
telling people what it is like living with Andrew,
Iris says that she likes Andrew a lot. As the
conversation goes further, it is clear to Terra
that her parenting partner is attracted to Andrew.
She asks the interviewer to cut the cameras
and storms off. When Iris is alone with the
interviewer in the kitchen she admits that she and
Andrew have fallen in love with each other. She
rushes outside to see him and the two get into a
heated discussion but things get more interesting
when they kiss. The kids watch them from nearby in
utter shock because they have never seen anything
remotely sexual between a man and a woman.
Terra witnesses this and sends the kids back
into the house. Meanwhile, the leader
of the men’s extremist group, Darius
comes forward with his claims that they are being
fed food mixed with estrogen so their sexual urges
would be suppressed. The men from the sanctuary go
on a hunger strike but it only lasts for a day and
a half. Darius pretends that they have decided
to keep eating the food so no one forgets what
the men going through in the sanctuaries. After
being found having an affair with his employer,
Andrew’s work permit is revoked and he
is sent to a sanctuary in Vancouver.
He lives there for a while but his mind and heart
are back at the house. He cannot get Iris out of
his head even for a second. The other men living
with him have given up because they do not have
any reason to want to go back to society but
Andrew is always thinking of a way to escape.
He somehow manages to send Iris a letter and
calls her to meet him outside the sanctuary. Then,
one night he escapes and finally reunites
with her. The two have nowhere to run
and they believe that their love is valid so
they hold a press conference instead. When
they logically explain their case to the people,
women start becoming more open to the concept
of helping men from becoming extinct. People
protest demanding the government to figure out a
way to help men. Their efforts pay off when Iris
and Andrew are legally allowed to get married.
With a lot of scientific research, Iris is
able to become pregnant with Andrew’s child.
Scientists disguised the XY chromosomes in
the sperm to make it seem like XX and hence,
Iris gets pregnant. The movie ends as Andrew says
that he doesn’t want the child to be a girl and
Iris looks at him in disappointment.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.